retail stores have struggled during the
pandemic but one clothing industry is
actually seeing business
increase chris martinez reports
just a couple of miles from the high
priced stores on beverly hills rodeo
drive
you'll find crossroads trading the
second hand store
let shoppers like johnny ibram pick up
fashionable items
for a fraction of the original price
depending on
what it is you can get up to like 50 to
70 percent off
the second hand industry is getting a
boost during the pandemic
it's not just shoppers looking for deals
during a struggling economy
thrift stores are receiving an increase
in donations
i think because of coba everyone's been
stuck at the house and so they're just
kind of cleaning and organizing out
their closets
online consignment store thredup has
more people looking to sell their items
and plenty of e-shoppers ready to buy
them during the pandemic and the
resulting economic crisis value is still
incredibly important
to consumers aaron wallace is with
thredup the company's annual report
predicts the second-hand apparel market
will grow from 28 billion to 64 billion
by 2024. there's been a real rise in the
interest in resale
primarily due to it being a far more
sustainable choice
for shoppers to make and obviously the
tremendous value how are you
sustainability is a big reason ibram
buys previously owned clothes
i have been able to sway a few friends
over to
like the green side as i like to call it
because it's
everyone's like oh my god i kind of see
why you're so into this it's been
great he sees it as a win-win keeping
clothes out of a landfill
while getting a great deal chris
martinez cbs news los angeles